e montagna
Oh
no
e niente di più
[Musica]
quale testo alla cannella per chi hanno
essere è essere con le fantasie che
essere il ragazzo che ho intenzione di creare per te è cambiare
in un ambiente senza legge in un mondo di
colori che contate ci provo
l'accensione di quelli veri si fa sul retro
con ciò che non ho visto ballando
in modo che la libertà tra ci sia
[Musica]
non piu
Sono più record è la gioia
[Musica]
Non camminerò un giorno
e niente
[Musica]
volantini matematici in ctl cantilever di
la storia del design trascende a
emozioni con un computer e lezioni con
interrogatori in branco prédiger bene
dietro l'immaginazione c'è
[Musica]
se quel cuore avesse creduto che sarebbe passato dentro
cum oggi
[Musica]
Oh
ma
[Musica]
questo materiale o se sono solo qui
la carità
Y
Così
[Musica]
così che l'ho liberata tra gli altri
Beh, ti ho ucciso completamente e loro sono qui
[Musica]
hai visto più ha detto che non poteva farlo
qualunque
[Musica]
perché
rendere molte notti di musica